[MUSIC PLAYING]
Poetry can make someone
fall in love with you.
Poetry can make you fall
in love with yourself.
I come to poetry because
of the questions.
What are we doing here?
Why?
Who would make a
place like this?
And there's no one answer.
It's to investigate.
Poetry became my
activism, my own way
of processing and dealing with
the Native rights movements.
It goes where words cannot go,
speaks what words cannot speak.
And so then the question
is, where do I start?
I'm offering you different
kinds of approaches
to poetry or to your
innate creativity.
In this class, we'll be talking
about imagery, writing, rhythm,
revision.
And it's good for anyone.
You don't have to be a poet.
Everyone's paths are different.
A line has to have a purpose.
Otherwise, it's
like a two-by-four
going through the middle
of the room for no reason.
What do you do if
you get blocked?
Go outside the predictability.
Take your failed
love poem and put it
in the shape of a recipe.
While I'm still waking up,
halfway in the dream space,
I just start writing for a
half hour without thinking.
Poems come through that were
beyond the thinking mind.
It will take you to other
levels of perception.
Poetry can open doors.
Poetry can open eyes.
It can take our grief and turn
it to the depth, the muscle,
the toughness you need
to be able to climb.
I am Joy Harjo, and
this is MasterClass.